give up that equity go raise it if you
can raise 10 million do it 50 million do
it this concept may make sense in
silicon valley because most people start
with an idea a team so they say okay i
want to go raise 50 million bucks i get
it if for anybody else that's running a
regular business that's maybe not in the
tech world you don't necessarily have to
go try to raise as much money as
possible here's why so what if i go
raise too much money and i go from you
know a 80 majority to all of a sudden a
49 majority now the board keeps telling
me what to do and i'm no longer a
founder i'm going back to having the
same exact position that i had
somebody's telling me constantly what to
do i don't want to give up that much
control so maybe the answer will be
raised as much money would i given up
control fine i'll buy that or
take your time raise a little bit of
money grow your business save the equity
so the next year when you go out and
raise money the company's worth 50
million dollars now you're not having to
give up 50 maybe you only sell that
percentage for 10 5 15 you keep more
equity for yourself and the business is
proven you're not going out there being
desperate to want to raise the money